second day of our vacation we are
heading to San Antonio Texas it's about
a 3-hour drive to get there we're going
to see some amazing caves and go country
dancing which is going to be fun but
before that Nina has to get her nails
done so I found a couple places for
nails she can tell you that story yeah
well cuz because my nails um was it
yesterday on the 26 I was no on the 25th
I was moving something and then my nail
chipped wait why are you moving
something instead of the husband I take
care of everything in the house so so I
was moving something that
sucks why are you laughing cuz you laugh
we laugh cuz you laugh cuz you have a
you have a you have an infectious laugh
that makes everybody around you
laugh this is the place where I'm going
to go I hope they have a spot for me
fingers crossed okay so so I just
finished 4 hours later let's see it no
not 4 hours an hour and a half later so
I I can't feel anything obviously cuz my
fingers are busy my hands are busy you
can think about your husband I did I got
really big head it inside because they
use a different things how the yeah so I
asked them for the mask so I don't smell
I don't smell the scents there anyways
this is a final product final product
yeah looking good oh also the uh you
left your jacket at the hotel oh jacket
at the hotel black jacket I didn't
believe oh I hang it out okay so we have
to go back we got to go back oh sorry so
that's fine who needs to go to San
Antonio
anyway we just stay in perfect let's
[Music]
go how you doing good getting hot uh no
well I was hot and then we realize how
to turn the air conditioning
on probably a good thing to figure out
when you're driving through through
Texas like it's so hot in here what's
happening they like oh air conditioning
I set it to 60° but it was still super
warm uh and then Nina figured out how to
turn on the fans to Auto so now now it's
great yeah we are 20 minutes away from
going to uh I think it's called
rapacious where it's this famous place
where they turn everything into wraps
hamburgers into wraps and other things
so I go there grab a grab a wrap to eat
and then finally make our way to the
caves and then go
dancing wish us luck is there a veggie
in the
WRA
uh I'm sure you can ask for whatever you
want to ask for cuz you said they can
turn anything into wraps yes so then
then yes if if they don't do it you can
say well my husband said that you could
so you better make it
happen
[Music]
all right we're just arrived at rapu
Evan's going to look up what we can eat
what we can eat yeah what we should eat
so it's known for the cheese burger wrap
okay tacos rattlesnakes rattlesnake
that's Toronto is that that's not
actually oh rattlesnake Burger okay what
else rattlesnake Burger High recommend
the rattlesnake Burger is it actually
made of
rattlesnake I'm going to go with the
cheeseburger okay and cheeseburger wrap
okay uh what should I
eat well any of the wraps cheeseburger
wrap tacos
rattlesnake craft beer I think we're
okay yeah those are the main things okay
this probably healthy rap though mhm BR
snakes are very healthy actually yeah I
read about that on the way up well while
I was driving yeah I read about it ding
rattlesnakes are basically vegetables so
I think you're good with that
[Music]
one you ready for your it's hot rouille
Ratatouille repe raptitude repit toe so
they have it's a
cheeseburger but it's in a wrap in a in
a spinach in a spinach wrap so it's
healthy and then there's
pickles cheeseburger and the fries are
inside too it's crazy very
[Music]
exciting oh yeah
yummy good I hold their salad but they
have a jalapeno on the salad so I'm
going to take it
out cuz I don't like too spicy it's
dressing on the side I didn't ask but
they put their dressing you're spicy as
a human yeah
[Music]
want let me try my I ordered the pport
rrap C pork well it's um in a spinach
wrap too so that must be
healthy yeah very good let's go the
owners are from Hawaii mhm and they do
pulled pork all the time so good job all
right good hey success Little Road stop
by the highway yeah really good
good peina means good things with new
nails too woo look at those Nails how's
the mail Evan I'm full how are you doing
good that was good I'm not too full but
it's good I'm not too full yeah it was
good I like it it's it's it makes a lot
of
sense what why like it it it's much
cleaner like if you're eating a big
burger has all that stuff you like the
burger the Patty starts falling out
other it just drips all over the place
it's hard to like eat around it right
for this is all contained it's a genius
idea and it's spinach so it's healthy
very healthy it's basically a health
food
right okay we finally get to go to the
caverns let's go to the caverns
woo what do we going to see here Evan I
think it's dripstone like dripstone
Caverns oh okay it looks cool the
picture so okay we'll see never been
before
[Music]
yeah what are you doing Evan getting
some
gold rails are Steep and wet with
steps I'm trying to read trails are
Steep and wet Evan are you ready for
this tour I'm so ready yeah I'm very
ready what did they did you pay
attention what he said they said they
might have bats so it was very excited
did he did he said don't shine the
lights because you might scare the bats
no he didn't say bat he said cave
Critters and in the gift shop it's all
bats take a guess of what that is that's
great and then he said if you when you
go in with one sty one hairstyle come up
with a different one are you ready for
that 99% humidity yeah
I'm coming out with an
[Music]
afro
how's your
hair think it's a think it grew a bit
there oh
yeah all those minerals that yummy
calite you know just uh going to wake up
tomorrow and have fil afro what's
happening oh it's nice to be uh it's
nice to be outside so we did you film
the water water no at the end the
drinking water no oh they they gave us a
fountain we could drink the cavern water
it was nice M refreshing yeah and now we
go outside it's it's so nice and cool
it's nice and cool it's great it was so
warm in there 99% humidity now I get to
go outside and have a refreshing walk I
like it that was a great experience yeah
it's yeah that was fun I'm glad we came
yeah good job okay now we're going to go
to uh I think it's called gron Hall I
don't know if I pronounce that properly
it's the largest dance hall I think in
America and they have dancing almost
every night of the year uh today is a
Wednesday night so it's not a big night
but uh they're still they're house band
playing so we're going to drive for
about 20 minutes check it out do some
dancing grab some
food uh and continue on with our evening
Let's Go San
[Music]
Antonio Evan you're very
excited
yeah let's do some
dancing
we did some salsa it was fun yeah and
then I was trying to pick up what the
footwork was for the Texas twep and then
one of the one of the women here saw and
and taught us the basics so then we
started doing the basics around and then
we started to improvise come up some
turns come some you know some stuff we
started getting it yeah yeah we can hold
around this is this is the most famous
dance hul in America and we went out and
we held our own let's go Nina come on
Nina car everybody Michael every I I
also I don't know if I can get it cuz I
there's hundreds of people watching yeah
and the first song we did there's only
two of us two couples on the whole floor
with hundreds we did salsa in front of
hundreds of Texans here it is great and
then we started doing the basics of tep
it was great it was great what an
experience gr Hall good job you did a
you did great well I can't to it by
myself yeah you know give it up for
[Music]
new next up we're going to find
something to eat eat because if I eat
too late I sleep very poly uh my
digestion system is not that great so we
need to eat be before I need to finish
before 8:00 then I could go to bed
potentially 11 right Evan Evan is still
dancing let's swing Rock Step 1 2
3 Step 1 2 3 oh what what are you
filming I was filming that we're going
to find some food to eat I don't know
where we at right now just all pitch
black it is why because it's dark where
are we going okay we found a place we're
going to something River Grill they have
salad okay good they have salad what are
you going to get I don't know as long as
you're happy okay then you're H then I'm
then as I'm happy you're happy that's a
good husband there
[Music]
yeah it's an hour wait so I'm not going
to wait an hour just for food so we're
going to find some something else yeah
it's fine yeah we'll
[Music]
see all right we arrived at our
hotel we're going to check out the room
yep lead the way okay this is our room
welcome this is a little area for what
do you call
vanity bathroom
shower coffee machine and Evan carich
and then this is our room it says
welcome Evan welcome Evan let's go and
then we got a KingSize bed oh we're
doing the KingSize bed yeah we didn't
get a we didn't get a two queen but no I
didn't choose I guess I don't remember
anyways we're here let's wash our hands
and go
[Music]
out yeah it's a very very live I like it
livelyhood
right by the water river walk water
we're going to
have dinner
here what are we having dinner Evan
Domingo highly
rated um and it's right below our hotel
which is nice and we're even outside we
have the fire pit and that's the
Riverwalk I'm really liking San Antonio
so far I don't know it's it's very the
vibe is very good yeah yeah yeah
different than Houston I'm liking it so
far so good okay what are we getting for
food oh uh what what uh was recommended
which is the uh short
Pia the fish tacos M and the green chile
and chicken enchiladas probably okay as
long it's not too
[Music]
spicy all right you just trying her
food it's uh I forget what it is she
says it's
enchilada with chicken chicken
mhm M it's just
okay just okay it's not like wrapped it
too all right it
took almost 2 hours to eat Nina just is
a very slow eater no the food took so
long to come out I almost want to cancel
our dessert order and just said you know
what I don't want to I don't want to
just cancel I'm going to leave and then
she said oh it's almost out and then we
waited for another 15 minutes yeah was
pretty long yeah it's not worth of going
but the atmosphere like the view is very
nice but the food just okay it's not as
good as it was mentioned on this on the
review the atmosphere was a 8 out of 10
yeah maybe n out of 10 was here was
pretty good service was like a 1 out of
10 she never came over ask if we want
more water I always have to ask for it
and then she never check on if the food
is okay and I asked for en chanella to
put the jalapeno on the side but it was
on the it was in the
dish but company was a 10 out of 10
let's go tomorrow is going to be a
fantastic day in San Antonio I'm so
excited if you want to see what we do
check it right there next to us you're
going to love it too continue to believe
we'll see you there right